>> THE FBI GETS REAMED FOR
CALLING PATRIOTIC FLAGS EXTREME.
ACCORDING TO THE FBI EVERY FLAG
IS A RED FLAG.
THIS WEEK SENATOR TED CRUZ
QUESTIONED OVER FBI TRAINING
MATERIALS THAT FLAG CERTAIN
FLAGS AS BEING SYMBOLS OF
MILITIAS.
AND WONDER IF THEY HAD PATRIOTI
SYMBOLS OF OUR NATION IN OUR
HISTORY?
GET THEY INCLUDED RATHER
ASTONISHINGLY PATRIOTIC SYMBOLS
OF OUR NATION IN OUR HISTORY.
INCLUDED ON THIS LIST IS THE
BETSY ROSS FLAG.
THAT IS FAIRLY REMARKABLE AS TH
ITSY ROSS FLAG IS INDICATIVE OF
MILITIA VIOLENT EXTREMISM.
>> I DIDN'T KNOW BETSY ROSS WAS
SUCH A LEAP.
SO WHAT DID ROSS DO THAT WAS
EXTREME?
SHE SEWED FLAGS.
BUT IT'S NOT THIS THE BETSY ROS
FLAG.
>> IT'S NOT JUST THE BETSY ROSS
FLAG, ALSO ON THIS LIST IS THE
GETZEN FLAG, AS A SYMBOL OF
VIOLENT EXTREMISM.
FOR THE STATE OF VIRGINIA HAS
LICENSE PLATE AS DO MANY OTHER
STATES.
>> THE GETZEN FLAG DATES BACK T
1775, THE YEAR BIDEN LEARNED TO
RIDE A BIKE.
WHAT ELSE WAS INCLUDED ON THE
LIST?
>> ALSO INCLUDED ON THIS LIST,
WAS PARTICULARLY STRUCK GONZALE
BATTLE FLAG.
I WILL SELF-REPORT RIGHT NOW
THAT EVERY DAY IN THE SENATE I
WEAR MY BOOTS THAT HAVE THE
GONZALES BATTLE FLAG ON THE BAC
OF THEM.
>> DIRECTOR RAY, WHAT ARE YOU
ALL DOING?
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> YOU KNOW HE MEANS BUSINESS
WHEN HE TAKES OFF HIS BOOTS.
THE EQUIVALENT OF ADAM SCHIFF
REMOVING HIS UNDERWRITERS.
WAS HE FAMILIAR WITH THE
PARTICULAR DOCUMENT HE HAD
BEHIND HIM?
AGAIN SENATOR I'M NOT FAMILIAR
WITH THE PARTICULAR DOCUMENT YO
HAVE BEHIND YOU, WE USUALLY MAK
GREAT PAINS, TAKE GREAT PAINS T
PUT CAVEATS AND WARNINGS IN THE
DOCUMENTS TO MAKE CLEAR THAT A
SYMBOL ALONE IS NOT CONSIDERED
EVIDENCE OF VIOLENT EXTREMISM.
KINCAID ELM AND ANDY BOTH LEGS
WERE NOT INCLUDED.
ALSO INCLUDED WAS THIS ONE.
THANK GOD BURNING THAT ONE IS
CONSTITUTIONALLY PROJECTED.
EVERYTHING YOU WHERE ACCORDING
TO THE FBI MAKES YOU A PERSON O
INTEREST.
>> I'VE GOT AND IT'S RIGHT HERE.
YOU HAVE BETSY ROSS ON ONE BICE
AND YOU'VE GOT THAT GETS IMPLIE
ON ANOTHER.
>> YOU ALSO HAVE.
>> IT'S A PLAY DAY.
APPARENTLY I'M TWO THIRDS OF A
MAN AND ALSO TWO THIRDS OF
TERRORIST.
>> YOUR 100 PERCENT ALL MAN AND
MY BOOK, JOEY.
I MEAN HOW RIDICULOUS.
AND THEN HIS ANSWER, THE CIVIL
WAR ALONE.
THOSE SYMBOLS MEAN YOU LOVE THE
COUNTRY AND YOU DON'T JUST FULL
TRUST THE GOVERNMENT AND THAT I
SOMEHOW A BAD THING?
LEE FOUNDED THIS COUNTRY ON
REBELLING FROM TYRANNY.
WE WROTE A CONSTITUTION AND NOW
PEOPLE THAT BELIEVE IN THAT, BU
THAT BELIEVE THOSE PRINCIPLES
ARE A PUBLIC THREATS BECAUSE
THIS COUNTRY IS EXPANDED TO THE
POINT THAT FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
YOU HAVE TO BELIEVE IN THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO BE SAFE
YOU HAVE TO BELIEVE IN IT SO
MUCH YOU DON'T NEED TO SPEAK
AGAINST IT, THAT'S WHY BIG TECH
IS ABOUT TO BREAK IT SCARES THE
TO DEATH TO HAVE AMERICANS THAT
STILL THINK TO THEMSELVES FOR
THINKING YOU MAY BE FAMILIAR
WITH THIS, DR. TRUE.
IT'S THE CRITERIA OF LINKAGE
GREAT ANYBODY CAN BE GUILTY OF
SOMETHING BECAUSE SOMEBODY ELSE
BAD IS DOING ITS GREAT IF YOU
DRIVE A VW, YOU NEVER THROUGH
TED BUNDY AND NAZIS.
KICK IT IT'S LIKE A VOLKSWAGEN
HITLER DROVE A VOLKSWAGEN PARRO
COULD GET YOU SOUGHT A LOT OF
THAT IN THE JANUARY 6 COMMITTEE.
THEY WERE SAYING IT'S POSSIBLE
THERE WAS MAY BE A HOW ARE THE
PEOPLE GOING TO FEEL WHEN A
FELONY MIGHT HAVE BEEN HAPPENED.
IT'S LIKE WELL, THESE
SPECULATIONS ARE ALL JUST
SOMETHING THEY HAVE NO RELEVANC
IN FACT.
WHAT KIND OF WORLD WE LIVE IN?
FACTS DON'T MATTER, LOGIC
DOESN'T MATTER.
EVERYTHING ELSE IS JUST A MORE
FEELING IN POLITICAL.
>> KAT, I THINK THE FBI IS IN A
PICKLE.
HOW CAN THEY INFILTRATE WHITE
TERROR GROUPS IF THEY CAN'T FIN
WHITE SUPREMACIST?
SO THEY HAVE TO ENLARGE AND
WIDEN THE NET TO INCLUDE JOEY?
>> I LEFT HIS NAME ON AN
ANONYMOUS TIP LINE.
>> YOU TO?
TO GET ALL OF THEM?
>> THIS IS WHY I THINK IT SO
IMPORTANT TO STAND AGAINST THE
SURVEILLANCE STATE OF MATTER HO
HARD THE GOVERNMENT TRIES TO
CONVINCE YOU THAT IS TO PROTECT
YOUR BIRD THAT'S WHAT I WAS
AGAINST THE PATRIOT ACT FROM TH
VERY BEGINNING.
I KNOW THAT SOMETHING WE ARGUED
ABOUT A FEW YEARS AGO.
ONCE YOU GIVE THE GOVERNMENT
THESE TYPES OF POWERS, IT'S THE
UP TO THEM TO DECIDE HOW TO USE
THEM AND THEY HAVE TO CONVINCE
YOU IT'S FOR YOUR PROTECTION,
ITCH OR PROTECTION COULD, BUT
THEY CAN USE IT ANY WAY THEY
WANT.
IT'S WRONG WITH WHAT IS
HAPPENING NOW, THE WHOLE THING
IS WRONG AND THEY SHOULDN'T BE
IN OUR BUSINESS.
>> IT'S THREE OF THE PUBLIC
HEALTH SYSTEM, THEY CALL IT A
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY.
>> THEY MAKE THIS A PUBLIC
HEALTH PROBLEM.
TO GET THEY CAN HAVE UNLIMITED
POWERS WHEN IT'S A PANDEMIC, AN
THAT MEANS TO BE RESTRICTED.
>> EMILY, MAY BE THE BLONDE LAD
OVER HERE IS RIGHT.
WE WERE WARNED ABOUT THIS, WE
WERE WARNED ABOUT THIS BY THE
LEFT, DO THEY TURN OUT TO BE
RIGHT WHEN SHE STARTED LOOKING
FOR A TERRORIST, YOU'RE GOING T
BE LOOKING FOR A DOMESTIC
TERRORIST TO, YOU COULD LABEL
ANYBODY?
GET THINK WHAT WE SAW IN THAT
HEARING IS THE ELEVATING
CIRCUMSTANTIAL EVIDENCE LIKE
THEY IMPORT WHICH MEANS YOU HAV
TO PUT A WHOLE BUNCH OF OTHER
THINGS IN THAT TO MAKE IT MEAN
SOMETHING, IT'S BEEN ELEVATED
NOW TO LIKE OH THIS IS ABSOLUTE
PROOF.
TO YOUR POINT IN THE INTRO,
THERE WAS A TOTAL ABSENCE OF AN
REFERENCE TO THEY HAVE DESTROYE
COMMUNITY AND LIVES, BUT IT WAS
ABSENT.
SENATOR CRUISE ALSO TESTIFIED
THERE BEEN MULTIPLE
INVESTIGATIONS BECAUSE PARENTS
BECAUSE OF THAT LETTER SENT.
THEY HAVE BEEN INVESTIGATIONS.
WE SENT YOU OVERSIGHT LETTERS
DETAILING MULTIPLE, MULTIPLE
INVESTIGATIONS INTO PARENTS THA
WERE UPSET ABOUT CRT AND THE
DELETION OF THEIR POWER OF OVER
THEIR CHILDREN'S EDUCATION.
THIS WAS WAS TO BE AN INHERENT
OF GOVERNMENT.
IN BETWEEN THEN AND NOW, IT HAS
BEEN COMPLETELY ERECTED INTO
THIS BLOATED BEAST THAT WE ARE
SUPPOSED TO SIT AND TAKE WITHOU
WITH UNLIMITED AUTHORITY.
EVERY DAY THAT GOES BY THAT
AUTHORITY GETS BIGGER AND
THERE'S NOTHING WE CAN DO ABOUT
GETTING SMALLER.
IT'S LIKE THE ABUSE THEY GETS
FED.
>> IT'S THE WOKE NATURE OF TRUT
ENTERING THE COURTROOM.
IS LATE JUST OR ARE THE ROLES
THAT HAVE BEEN INTRODUCED.
>> THAT HAS STATED IS STILL HOLD
.
>> THIS IS MY SHOW.